let's bring in Sam holder he's our
reporter at the scene in Redding Sam
clearly now a huge area is a crime scene
what's the latest yeah that's right
there's a huge police presence here at
the moment and large parts of Redding
town center are closed off there are
police checkpoints like this around the
town here we've got three police
officers a police car and actually
behind that arch is the park itself and
there's a number of police officers in
there it's very difficult to actually
navigate around reading at the moment
because of all these police checks there
are road closures all over the place and
you can hear every few minutes sirens of
ambulances and undercover police
officers there's also in the distance a
helicopter going on this really is for
berry gardens in the heart of Redding
it's a busy park it's a beautiful park
it's one where people will have been out
in force anyway on a sunny day like
today but particularly with this black
lives matter protest earlier in the
afternoon again it's worth stressing the
Thames Valley police say there's no
indication of any link between that
black lives matter protest or rally and
the expected terrorist incident this
evening but clearly this from from the
number of police here from the sirens
you can tell how seriously officers are
taking this and even now a few hours on
they're still in an enormous presence
here and people are being asked to move
on whenever they get too close yeah I
was gonna ask you about that Sam the
leader of Redding Council are urging
people to stay away but clearly people
are going to be wondering what's
happening eep-eep around we saw a couple
about an hour ago but there's an
encouragement to move on and people are
understanding of that and there is a
really big cordon in place which means
for most positions around the city you
can't really see into the park this is
about as close as you can get and
obviously it's dark in there so people
you know are coming and taking photos
and updating Facebook and then moving on
relatively quickly but the other problem
is that actually because of all these
row
closures it's really difficult to get
anywhere if people end up driving around
in circles because every road they try
and go down is closed and there's
nowhere to stop so the streets are
pretty quiet at the moment far more
police the members of public